ne peut souvent à gazon savoir quand
est-ce que ça va se terminer pour
retrouver une vie normale
certains symptômes persistent et tout ce
qui est d'où leur essoufflement perte de
concentration terre de mémoires
difficultés à suivre une conversation
avec xbox mes enfants ma femme ou autre
est toujours pas repris l'activité
professionnelle à cause de tout ça
bonjour le but du jeu c'est de vous
essouffler de voir comment ça se passe à
les souffleuses vous après on avait très
peur que il ya des lésions de tissus et
des ions d'organes qui s'installent ou
ou qu'on n'ait pas vu avec le recul
qu'on a on a la confirmation qui a pas
de fibrose pulmonaire qu'il n'y a pas de
lésion du coeur et qu'en fait c'est
vraiment votre système de réglage
intérieur qui a été détraqué par le
virus et qu'il faut il faut il faut le
remettre bien il faut le leur et du
livre vous leurrez habitués du coup je
fais du vélo j'ai un vélo d'appartement
j'ai acheté mes
corps moi j'ai remarqué comme quand je
fais ça ou réveille le matin c'est une
journée où je veux pas vendre un coup de
fatigue plus trop tôt dans la journée
vous avez une espèce d'arbre nations
dont on comprend pas le mécanisme mais
vous nous décrivez tout cela le jour
donc on s'est dit alors il nous raconta
problème d'inflammation essayer des
interrogatoires et il trouve que ça
fonctionne chercheurs traitement ça
marche plutôt pas mal et en particulier
moi j'aurais envie de vous proposer de
la cortisone à petite dose parce que
pour vous permettre de sortir de ce qui
vous reste de cet état là plus vite
bon ben c'est une bonne nouvelle très
bien que s'ils ont deux kinés vous en
avez encore n'en fait rien faire faire
une ordonnance soit là et là du coup un
joueur vous avez repris aussi un peu la
masse musculaire en big or c'est bien
bah ça je travaille j'ai toujours un peu
remué et puis là faut qu'il continue de
travailler sur la respiration
merci beaucoup au revoir monsieur ta
soeur et jeudis vous j'ai secret alors
on va se revoir fin juillet très bien
merci à mme marois ce qui m'a intéressé
c'est de transposer ce que j'ai appris
auprès des sportifs de haut niveau
parce que quand on a un syndrome de
surentraînement
il ya une partie de ces symptômes qu'on
va retrouver dans les communes où l'on
c'est pour ça aussi que j'y ai pensé
c'est que le surentraînement va
provoquer ce dérèglement du système
neurovégétatif et que c'est des choses
que j'ai déjà rencontré avec des
sportifs de haut niveau
ce virus-là donne une forme un peu
particulière et on arrive à se
raccrocher sur les choses qui nous
permettent de proposer des solutions de
ce problème c'est que aujourd'hui il
faut avoir du personnel pour détacher
des médecins des infirmières des
psychologues des diététiciennes et
kinésithérapeute pour s'occuper d'une
pathologie
émergentes nouvelles et qui ont qui
touchent des gens jeunes actifs souvent
en plaire aux mères de famille et que
c'est ce sont les forces vives de la
nation si je peux cliquer et rimer avec
des mois un peu pompeux et qu'il faut
absolument qu'on arrive à les sortir de
cette situation et qu'on s'occupe d'eux
correctement